vielleicht irgendwas elektro oder so was
ist das denn
nein nicht schon wieder jedesmal alter
das ist ja ein riesending leute was soll
ich sagen es hört nicht auf
ja und damit etwas geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich wird es gut vor
ungefähr einen monat oder ich glaube so
lange ist es noch gar nicht her kam auf
jeden fall mein video ich packe amazon
produkte aus sehe ich niemals bestellt
habe und darin habe ich schon gesagt so
ok ihr könnt gerne meine kommentare
schreiben woran das liegt oder was eure
meinung ist auf jeden fall bekomme ich
seit geraumer zeit an meine kölner
adresse ganz ganz viele am atompaket
eigentlich so jede woche zwei stück das
sie sind jetzt die letzten nicht
erhalten habe man muss auch sagen ich
bin umgezogen ich wohl nicht mehr in
serie und ich habe meinen nachbarn
gesagt bitte nehmt einfach nichts mehr
für mich an weil ich schon hier und da
mal ein bisschen bedenken hatte dass das
vielleicht irgendwie betruges oder so
ich muss sagen ich habe auch mit amazon
telefoniert mit irgendeiner innen
kompetenten mitarbeiterinnen aus irgend
einem callcenter auf den fragen wenig
inseln die hat irgendwie gar nicht
verstanden was ich ihr so mitteilen
wollte meinten aber dass sie das mal an
die sicherheitsabteilung weitergibt und
die meldet sich bei mir falls da
irgendwas mit betrug vorliegt das ganze
ist jetzt auch schon so zwei wochen er
ich habe nichts gehört von daher denke
ich einfach mal das sind alles
irgendwelche promo pakete oder meine
adresse ist irgendwo gelandet wo halt
leute paket hin schicken damit sie bei
amazon höhere verkäufe sozusagen
generieren und dadurch den höher gehängt
werden kein partner ist platt es sind
auf jeden fall echt cool sagen dabei ich
habe in zwei pakete schon reingeguckt
und jetzt einfach mal wir mit das hier
ist erste ja ach so wird ein letztes mal
habe ich viel davon weggeschmissen das
will ich jetzt nicht noch mal machen
schreibt einfach eine coole kommentar
und irgendwann kriegt dann alle sachen
weil ich habe keinen bock sodann in
verschiedenen leute auszusuchen und da
kriegt ein paket dagegen ein paket
irgendwie kriegt alles schreibt sie die
kommentare so als erstes haben wir hier
ein kleiner ok cherie
das kennt man die marke oder alter sogar
ein ganzes set hier da kann man sich
richtig schöne augenbrauen mit kreieren
absolut geil
also was ist bestimmt nicht günstig oder
ich schaue auch immer den wert nach
bisher ganz klar 16 eur 19 immerhin
wobei ich sagen muss irgendwie eine das
ist nicht genau das gleiche
die produkte die ich von amazon bekommen
die hier land und die gibt es in
deutschland gar nicht mit prime oder
irgendwie die die werden mir gar nicht
angezeigt zumindest die meisten das ist
so verrückt aber hier ist halt dass
amazon.com von amazon na ja danke auf
jeden fall für dieses set ich kann damit
absolut nix anfangen aber vielleicht ja
irgend jemand von euch und pinsel ist
auch noch dabei mach mal
heute nächste produkt was ist das denn
ok das habe ich noch nie gesehen so was
a
ich glaube ich weiß es das sind zu
figuren die kann man so irgendwie
vorstellen und daraus so was bauen
jetzt habe ich hier zum beispiel heute
was soll das sein
ganz klar wir haben ja einen krieger mit
einer waffe in der hand
also damit weiß ich überhaupt nichts
anzufangen aber nice to have hier haben
wir jetzt aber eine sache
das habe ich schon gesehen und zwar
wirklich wirklich cool wir haben hier
ein touch display also sozusagen ein
sensor seifenspender und die behalte ich
tatsächlich messbar
wir machen denn erstmal auf das ist doch
wirklich mal nicht schlecht da kommt
dann hier oben wahrscheinlich frau ach
so wie hinten kommen dann drei batterien
rein und dann hat man den iran machen
und einfach seine hand durchsuchen
städten in denen klappt so rum natürlich
ich musste gerade erst mal ein bisschen
überleben könnte ich jetzt natürlich mal
ausprobieren aber ich glaube jeder von
euch weiß wie so etwas funktioniert wir
machten ganz guten eindruck ist bestimmt
auch nicht so günstig also den behalte
ich auf jeden fall den rest hier nicht
kommen ja schon zur nächsten paket das
hier habe ich noch nicht geöffnet hier
ist aufgebraucht
da muss man vorsichtig mit seinen jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt vielleicht
irgendwas elektro
oder so was ist das denn
nein nicht schon wieder jedesmal alter
das ist ja ein riesending
das ist wirklich nicht zu fassen ich
weiß nicht ich muss das wahrscheinlich
wieder zensieren wir haben hier ein
sowie smart server automatik ich dachte
erst damit kann man so wasser auf
sprudeln so sieht das ein bisschen aus
aber nein es ist natürlich ein mail
masturbation cup also ich habe
mittlerweile schon so viele solche
sachen weil ja da gibt es ganz viele
anbieter einstellen da bin ich jetzt
einfach mal neugierig also für euch ist
das die ganze zeit zensiert das tut mir
sehr leid aber muss ich machen sonst
wird das video ab 18 geschaltet einer
was ist das denn film gerät
naja mein lieber herr gesangsverein
ich würde so gern jetzt hier sachen
erzählen aber es geht nicht mal das ist
halt so ein gerät gut wir verstehen das
erstmal das ist jetzt nicht weiter für
dieses video gedacht dass verlost sich
aber nicht dass bald erste stehen oder
was auch immer damit passieren wird ich
muss aber auch ganz ehrlich sein ich
würde so etwas nicht verwenden einfach
weil ich nicht weiß wo es herkommt
ich weiß nicht was wäre das schon
angefasst hat und da will ich nicht mehr
nächstes produkt wird sich auf jeden
fall schon wieder reingeschaut und zack
wir haben hier erstmal ziemlich
unspektakulär hunde augentropfen also
wenn euer hund mal irgendwas mitte augen
hat kann man das vielleicht verabreichen
natürlich auch wieder made in china dann
haben wir hier als nächstes ein
eishockey fitness band absurde
tschuldigung nicht eishockey fitness
band ich weiß das sind diese bänder da
kannst du so anziehen und so ein
bisschen muskeln aufbauen auch nichts
spektakuläres hat wahrscheinlich jeder
von euch schon mal gesehen deswegen
führe ich das auch schnell mal wieder
zurück und zu guter letzt ein sport
football ist das sind okay das sieht ja
interessant aus so was habe ich noch nie
gesehen hintendrauf schnitt der rutsche
über jede glatte oberfläche das
probierte aus
[Musik]
jetzt müssen wir vier batterien rein
moment ich bin gleich wieder da seid ihr
bereit
okay okay also gebt euch das ding
cristiano ronaldo boom und ab ins
wohnzimmer und durch die beine
übersteiger 1 2 patrick zack zack gmbh
also das werde ich auf jeden fall auch
behalten wir werden eine menge spaß
haben und das war vielleicht etwas fest
zu erzielen
[Musik]
die kaputte schon was jetzt
es gibt wirklich nichts was es nicht
gewinnen
ok letztes paket 1 am brandort so was
haben ok habe mir ein leider so ein
produkt aber besser als keines virtual
reality headset ok headset so eine
richtige virtual reality also das ist
wirklich eine vr pille
sowas hatte ich noch nie ich hatte nur
so ein ding normal sein handy
einschieben kann
ich kann mir jetzt hier eben eine app
download das mache ich auf jeden fall
mal weil ich wollte das schon immer
ausprobieren hallo
ja das kann ich hier durch sehen jetzt
nicht mehr
ach so leute doch nicht dass es wieder
nur so ein ding wo man sein handy
vornherein stecken kann also es sieht
zwar sehr professionell aus aber an sich
absolut hammel das ist wirklich also ich
hab so ein ding schon mal zugeschickt
bekommen und ich habe selten so ein
unnötiges produkt wie das hier gesehen
also das kann ich wirklich keinem
empfehlen absoluter mist da wird dir nur
schlecht von na ja das war's ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen das zu verändern
aber um die abonnierten kanal und wir
sehen uns morgen und 19 wieder gibt es
neues video und du kannst dein handy
dann damit connecten und kann so games
zocken und dabei kotzen dann das war es
heute
tja und denkt an den kommentar weil
einer kriegt alle sachen ich brauchte
ihn nicht